now Israel is urging citizens in the
north to shelter after what the Army
called hostile aircraft entering from uh
Lebanon aljaz javara aleri is live for
Us From Galilee in Northern Israel what
are you learning
[Music]
Shar
namely gani Crossroads the sirens
started to sound and as we speak the
Israeli internal front says that there
is man hunt by the Israeli Air Forces
Against drones and gliders to the north
of the country the last 30 minutes has
witnessed rapid development ments there
are also fears that
new gunmen would be infiltrating into
the occupied
territories and still as we speak isra
Israeli war planes are shelling shaba
forms throughout the Israel Sirens have
been
soundings including the ceasefire line
with Syria along the Goan OCC hi Goan
height also a rocket was shell was fired
from Gaza Strip following
which Sirens started to sound at the
same time the Israeli skies were
violated by 15 drones and glider the
Israeli air defenses and war
planes are searching and combing the
skies more than 2 million Israelis are
requested to stay in bunkers and
shelters from haa up to the north about
60 km long this is the biggest
development since the beginning of
today's fighting until this moment no
damages or injuries have been reported
however this is the very few minutes
since this news erupted and as I said
since we arrived at this very important
conjunction to the north of Galilea we
have seen unprecedented movement
movement to armored vehicle police and
army personnel carriers
even uh before the sirens
sounded after that it was established
that a missile was fired from Gaza a
shell from the southern parts of
Lebanon and as you see behind me all the
vehicles are rushing to the
north now we can say that the North
Front is
hot namely the southern of Lebanon and
the North of
Israel
however we can also say that the
ceasefire line on the Eastern Front with
the occupied Gan Heights is
also joined the action Israeli
authorities say that all the residents
of
haa from hia up to the North of
Israel more than 2 million Israelis are
forced to remain in shelters bunkers
underground also one of the most uh or
the biggest hospitals of hia
was or declared a state of
emergency it is considered to be the
most on the biggest medical facility in
haa all these developments unfolded as
the Israeli government announced to have
formed the war emergency Council as
formed by the head of the government
Benjamin
Netanyahu the
former along with his ally Ben the
former Defense Minister it is called a
war cabinet four officials in addition
to Netanyahu defense
minister and his colleague the former
Chief of Staff as well as nor dreier we
are speaking of a war cabinet and
emergency government these were formed
and as this announcement was made all
these rapid developments unfolded to the
east of Israel and to the north with the
Border Lines of Southern
Lebanon Shing stretch it from haa up to
the north now Netanyahu has arrived at
the premises of the
defense Ministry for an urgent security
briefing that's all javar aleri from our
assistant Network Al Arabic thank you
very much for very latest there